Daniela compró papas en el mercado y pago
"p"/7 de dólares por 2/9 de libras,
vamos a marcar los 2/9 de libras.
Si las papas tienen un costo "r" dólares
por cada libra, vamos a marcar los "r" dólares,
éste es otro dato importante, por cada libra,
que la manejaremos como dólares sobre libra,
¿qué información de la siguiente es verdadera
para los posibles valores de "p" y "r"?
Vamos a seleccionar todo lo que aplica.
Y aquí con estos datos podemos saber que
si yo tengo una cantidad "x" de producto,
que en este caso fue 2/9, y que si por ellos
pagamos un precio,
que está establecido que en este caso fue "r",
tendremos entonces el precio total que hemos pagado por esta cantidad de producto.
Que si lo vemos en nuestros datos, son "p/7.
En este caso nos están solicitando tener
la información para "p" y para "r",
y en la respuestas tenemos, la solución para "p",
la solución para "r",
primero vamos a despejar "p" para saber si tenemos información adecuada al respecto.
Si nosotros tenemos esta información,
pues podemos ver que nada de esto es lo que tenemos en las respuestas,
así es que vamos a manipularlo
de tal manera que tengamos primero "p",
para que nosotros podamos despejar la "p", lo que
vamos a hacer es multiplicar por 7,
ambos lados de la ecuación.
Y de esta manera se cancelan estos 7 y tendremos
"p" de este lado
y del lado izquierdo tendremos 7 por 2 es igual a 14/9, que están multiplicando a "r".
Y con esto tenemos el despeje de "p", vamos
a ver si alguno de estos despejes nos incluye "p",
de tal manera que tengamos esta información.
"p" es igual a 14/9 por "r", es exactamente esta misma información, solo que está al revés, ¿se dan cuenta?
pero es correcto, dado que aquí podemos considerar
que "14/9r" está multiplicando a 14/9 por "r",
así es que seleccionaremos esta primer
casilla como dato correcto o verdadero.
Vamos ahora a despejar "r".
Y para que podamos despejar a "r", multiplicaremos
ambos lados de la ecuación por 9/14...
así es que multiplicaremos por 9/14... de igual
manera que aquí multiplicaremos por 9/14
y con esto se cancelan y tendremos entonces
"r" es igual a "p" por 9/14,
¿tenemos algo así?
Bueno, definitivamente no es ésta y sí tenemos,
9/14 por "p" es igual a "r",
por lo que también seleccionaremos esta segunda opción como respuesta correcta.
Finalmente vamos a saber si este despeje de
14/9 es igual a "p" por "x".
Tomaremos entonces la versión original que
teníamos aquí.
14/9 por "r" será igual a "p" y lo reescribiré de este lado.
14/9 que están multiplicando a "r" serán igual a "p".
Y para que nosotros hagamos el despeje de
14/9, lo que haremos es dividir ambos lados
de la ecuación entre "r", de tal manera que
se cancela la "r" de este lado y se divide "p" entre "r".
Y con eso tenemos el despeje de 14/9.
14/9 es igual a "p" entre "r", no por "r",
de tal manera, ésta tampoco es una respuesta válida.
Con eso solo tendremos estas dos casillas
seleccionadas como respuestas adecuadas.